>> Bill: FOR MORE ON THIS MARC
DANNELS JOINS US FOR THE
CONDITIONS ON THE BORDER IN
ARIZONA.
GRIFF JENKINS IS IN MEXICO
ACROSS THE BORDER FROM
BROWNSVILLE, TEXAS WHAT IS
HAPPENING INSIDE A MIGRANT CAMP
THERE.
GRIFF, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THAT’S RIGHT.
WE’RE JUST OUTSIDE THE CAMP
THAT CLOSED AND DHS WHITE HOUSE
TEAM CAME ACROSS THE BORDER
FROM HIM.
A LOOK, THOUGH, WE HAVE A DRONE
SHOT THAT WILL TAKE NOW THIS
RIVER T RIO GRANDE RIVER IS THE
U.S. MEXICO BORDER.
BROWNSVILLE TEXAS AND RIO
GRANDE VALLEY ON THAT SIDE.
THIS CAMP WAS OPEN FOR TWO
YEARS PUT IN PLACE WHEN THE
TRUMP-ERA POLICY REMAIN IN
MEXICO KEPT ASYLUM SEEKERS ON
THIS SIDE OF THE BORDER WAITING
FOR THEIR CLAIMS TO PLAY OUT.
GUESS WHAT?
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS IT HAS
CLOSED.
MOST ALL OF THE INHABITANTS
INSIDE THIS CAMP WERE ALLOWED
TO CROSS INTO THE U.S. AND MANY
OF THEM RELEASED AT THAT BUS
STATION WE SAW IN BROWNSVILLE.
ALL YOU ARE LOOKING ATAT NOW IS
THE DEBRIS AND TRASH WITHIN
THIS CAMP THAT ACCRUED OVER TWO
YEARS.
THE NGO ORGANIZATION DOCTORS
WITHOUT BORDERS CALLING IT
INHUMANE CONDITIONS FOR ANYONE
TO LIVE IN.
MANY OF THEM FAMILIES, A LOT OF
CHILDREN.
A VERY DIFFICULT PLACE TO SPEND
UPWARDS OF TWO YEARS.
WE TALKED TO SOME OF THE
MIGRANTS THAT WERE STILL OUT
HERE THAT HAVEN’T BEEN ALLOWED
TO CROSS.
ONE OF THEM IS A GENTLEMAN
NAMED MARIO WITH HIS FAMILY
HERE FROM HONDURAS AND BEEN
HERE EIGHT MONTHS TRYING TO
CROSS.
HE BELIEVES THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE MORE
FAVORABLE TO HIS CAUSE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> THE PRESIDENT, UNITED
STATES, BIDEN, HELP THE PEOPLE.
IT IS NECESSARY, YOU KNOW, WE
DON’T HAVE NOTHING HERE.
>> AS WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THIS DRONE SHOT OF THIS CAMP,
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS, BILL.
MOST OF THE MIGRANTS WHO WERE
IN THIS CAMP HAVE CROSSED INTO
BROWNSVILLE.
UNDER THE CATCH AND RELEASE
PROTOCOLS OF THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATION, WE HAVE
BRAND-NEW NUMBERS OUT OF THE
CITY OF BROWNSVILLE WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COVID
TESTING OF THESE MIGRANTS.
THAT’S WHAT’S NEW ABOUT THIS
CRISIS.
IT IS IN A PANDEMIC, NOT LIKE
ONE IN 2014 OR 2019.
NEW NUMBERS YOU CAN SEE HERE ON
THE SCREEN 185, THAT’S UP FROM
108 THE LAST UPDATE WE HAD LAST
WEEK.
IT HAS BEEN 1,553 MIGRANTS
TESTED IN BROWNSVILLE SINCE
JANUARY.
WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT AND FIND
OUT IF THAT NUMBER CONTINUES TO
GROW.
ONE THING IS FOR SURE, MOST OF
THE MIGRANTS WHO WERE IN THIS
CAMP BEHIND ME HAVE EITHER
CROSSED OR SOME OF THEM HAVE
MOVED TO THE INTERIOR.
WHAT MEXICAN OFFICIALS ARE A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE GREEN LIGHT
THAT HAS BEEN PERCEIVED BY MANY
OF THE MIGRANTS TO COME NOW
DESPITE THE ADMINISTRATION
TELLING THEM NOT TO THAT THEY
WILL COME FROM HONDURAS,
GUATEMALA AND EL SALVADOR.
THERE ARE A FEW MIGRANT
SHELTERS THROUGHOUT THE CENTER
AND WE’LL GO DEEPER INTO MEXICO
A LITTLE LATER AND SEE WHAT’S
HAPPENING AT THOSE SPOTS.
>> Dana: GRIFF, I WANTED TO ASK
A QUESTION.
YOU SAID SOMETHING IN YOUR
REPORT THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
YOU SAID THAT REPRESENTATIVES
FROM DOCTORS WITHOUT BORDERS
HAVE DESCRIBED IT AS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I HAVE THAT
RIGHT.
GET A LITTLE MORE ON THAT.
>> THEY’VE DESCRIBED THE
CONDITIONS WHEN THIS CAMP WAS
OPEN AS INHUMANE CONDITIONS.
THEY DIDN’T SAY A CRISIS FROM
WHAT I’VE READ OF WHAT THEY
SAID.
BUT HERE IS THE THING BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD THIS SEMANTIC
DEBATE AND I’VE COVERED THIS
ISSUE SINCE I COVERED TWO
CARAVANS AND TRAVELED FROM
HONDURAS THROUGH GUATEMALA TO
MEXICO A LITTLE WEST OF ME AND
THEY WENT TO EAGLE PASS.
BEFORE THAT TO TIJUANA.
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WE KNOW JAY JOHNSON SAID IF YOU
THINK OVER A THOUSAND A DAY IS
A CRISIS.
GOING BY HIS METRIC WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE LAST SEVEN DAYS
ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN 10,000
APPREHENSIONS IN JUST THE RIO
GRANDE SECTOR.
I TALKED TO AN OFFICIAL EARLY
THIS MORNING.
THEY TOLD ME THEY ARE HOLDING
2600 IN CAPACITY IN THEIR
DETENTION CENTERS AND ONLY HAVE
CAPACITY UNDER COVID FOR 700.
HE TOLD ME IN A TEXT MESSAGE WE
CAN’T CATCH AND RELEASE THEM